So, this is my update for the project.
I have improved the record audio functionality.
As you can see, we can start recording and there is an option to stop it and pause it.
You cannot cancel it in between.
It will show you a notification, you have unsaved notification, unsaved recording, are
you sure you want to leave, your recording will be lost.
We will press cancel, recording will start from as usual, we can stop the recording now.
Again, without a update, uploading, if we cancel it, we will again get a notification
that do you want to save the recording, we press cancel, we can even refresh it and we
will get another problem, changes that you may not be saved, you just cancel.
Here we can upload it.
Once we upload it, we will redirect it to the audio analysis page.
Here we can preview our recording.
If we press transcribe, here you can see without transcription, summarization is disabled,
we will press transcribe, we will get a banner, transcription started and a skeleton loading
effect.
After some time, transition will be done and this is transcript and it is now enabled,
summarization.
So, we will press summarization now, summarization has started, as you can see the skeleton
loading effect, here summarization is done, we will click cancel, this is the summary.
Now we will go back to the dashboard, we can see our recording has been added, if we click
on it, we will go to the audio analysis page, let's go back again and let's try to close
the server once.
So, here we will close the server and we will refresh it, we have got the error occurred
while fetching files, we refresh after some time, we have got a no file, so here we have
got feedback that we have files, but due to some error, we cannot see them correctly,
we will just close it and that's it.